[Music]
what's going on everybody ian harditz
here from pfff ready to talk some
fantasy football how about that rams it
builds tonight let me go through some
other things around the league first
though before we get started with some
of the worst matchups of the week got
some injuries that we need to be keeping
an eye on here with nfl back guys are
getting banged up left and right most
notably today rondale moore cardinal
starting slot receiver hurt the
hamstring in practice getting the mri
done we don't know yet but guys right
now no hopkins no rondelle moore zac
erch is banged up marquise hollywood
brown needs to be in fantasy lines of
all shapes and sizes if you can show me
a lineup that does that shouldn't have
marquis brown in it i am telling you to
quit playing in four or six team leagues
because i do not think it exists also
out wide receiver isaiah mckenzie
tonight the bill's starting slot
receiver good to go with the groin
injury so if by some chance you were
planning on stuttering ron dale more
isaiah mckenzie is a pretty good
replacement for him that i honestly
would rank just a little bit higher this
week to begin with also keep an eye on
alan lazard aaron rodgers number one
wide receiver got stepped on last week
was not able to practice at all on
wednesday bad way to start the week on
the other side of good things though
chris goblin don't we don't we love
modern science my goodness guy tears his
acl in january comes back and practices
in full on wednesday seems to have a
realistic chance to shoot to actually
suit up sunday night against the cowboys
keep an eye on the deontay johnson
shoulder injury guys in this matchup
nick and chidobia wuzier from the
bengals is going to shadow deontay
johnson that's what happened last year
that leaves eli apple that's right eli
apple trying to check mr george pickens
however if deontay's out that could
change things so just keep an eye out on
that jk dobbins limited with the knee
injury lamar jackson said he's going to
actually be weeks away so wouldn't
really count on dobbins this week mike
davis did pretty good waiver wire claim
if you are desperate also note that
miles sanders is good to go with the
hamstring final one though guys george
kittle limited with the groin and wasn't
even able to practice on thursday so
might need a tight end to get by irv
smith gerald everett my two best choices
for that
all right everyone this is br fantasy
presented by state farm i'm your host
ian hart
lovely lead fantasy football expert at
pff here to talk about some of the worst
week one match-ups yeah we have football
now how great is this the mock drafts
are over starting about season long
nonsense it's all over we're here in
week one let's try to win this week and
go get a fantasy championship so i have
five players that i'm not full fading
i'm not telling you to cut them if
they're on your team and just you know
pick up some random guy off the street
but i think because of the matchup
they're in we at least need to reduce
our expectations so starting things off
tonight los angeles rams quarterback
matthew stafford facing the buffalo
bills this is a combination of multiple
factors for me now we have the elbow
injury that ian rappaport comes out
today and says it's no big deal matthew
stafford clayton kershaw used to play
baseball together has anyone ever heard
this before similar injury and they're
talking about it not being a big deal
for stafford now if it's not a big deal
why would we just talk about it for the
last two months i don't know it's not
ideal i would rather not to talk about
the elbow at all bigger issue is the
bills reigning number one defense and
fantasy points per game allowed to the
quarterback position that means
quarterbacks were not scoring points
against the bills last season not a good
thing and yes number one cornerback
trudavius white is on the pup list to
start the season with that said a guy by
the name of von miller now resides in
buffalo that's problematic against the
los angeles rams offensive line that is
now moving on without long time left
tackle andrew whitworth so with matthew
stafford this week it's just one of
these matchups where the secondary spot
isn't great i mean i you can see his
chart here on the screen i like to look
at basically what the offense and
defense do together because whenever we
do this with every matchup question you
know offense rakes x defense ranks why i
combined those statistics and just get a
one-way metric to basically analyze
these mismatches and you can see it
really for josh allen as well but
matthew stafford just a middling matchup
in this one so it's not a great spot
yeah the game itself has a 52 point over
under but the rams are only applied for
24.75 points that's actually behind like
the dolphins and broncos this week so i
prefer aaron rodgers derek carr even
kirk cousins who we're going to talk to
in a second over matthew stafford i
really think you can make an argument
that justin feels maybe even jameis
winston our preferred players over
stafford this week so if he's the only
guy and it's between stafford and tua or
trevor lawrence or something that's okay
go ahead and go with stafford either way
he's gonna be back in the qb1
conversation next week against the
falcons
mentioned him before kirk cousins is
another guy that i'm just not lining up
to start this week and look i'm not
trying to just pick you know stafford
and cousins taking the easy way out
these are two quarterbacks that
legitimately have you know high 4 000
yard upside with the potential to throw
for 30 40 touchdowns on a yearly basis
so again not fully hating on cousins and
stafford i am hating on the matchup
though lost in the whole offseason of
aaron rodgers is the reality that this
might be the best packers defense that's
actually been on the field for green bay
during aaron rodgers entire tenure there
and kirk cousins going up against his
potential juggernaut could be
problematic so i'm not a kirk cousins
defender i would say but he's really
good when he's given the benefit of a
clean pocket think of kirk cousins as a
jimmy garoppolo type where when you know
the play happens as the coach drew it
out cousins can stand in there and throw
a rope things dissolve fast though once
it gets under pressure and comparing you
know as we're going to look at one of my
lovely charts here again looking at the
pressure rates of week one just in terms
of the offensive line and defensive line
kirk cousins has the second highest
combined pressure rate of the week and
last year he just so happened to be the
second most impacted quarterback in
terms of the largest yards per attempt
drop off when kept clean versus under
pressure you know just the easy way of
saying that kirk cousin sucks when he's
under pressure and the green bay packers
sure look like they're gonna have every
opportunity to have their way without
vikings offensive line they did make
some improvements but with that said
this is still pff's 19th ranked
offensive line going into the season i'm
not expecting kirk cousins to be
flirting with one of his upper end
outcome performances once again i prefer
rogers and carr and if you're looking
between fields and jameis winston versus
kirk cousins i honestly think you might
have a decent point there vikings
implied the score just 22.75 points the
washington commander what we're calling
them these days are literally implied to
score more points than the minnesota
vikings this week so not out in the
vikings offense on the year justin
jefferson's fine adam theon will be fine
kirk cousins this week though i am not
loving it
appreciate all you guys getting in the
chat here just gonna answer a few of
these real quick sitting the bills
defense tonight i would prefer the 49ers
broncos colts and even the browns to the
bills d just kind of streaming it is cam
akers good enough to start yeah it
depends on the lineup he's in my rb 26
this week one of those things where
we're gonna know a lot more about that
situation after uh honestly maybe the
first quarter of tonight's game in terms
of how sean mcvay plans on using those
running backs also dawson knox or cole
comet got to be dawson knox for me you
just see that money he got and uh with
corco met in chicago i just it sucks
guys but i think ryan griffin is going
to play a lot more in this offense than
giving credit for but back to another
worst case matchup ahead of week one
it's ezekiel elliott against the
buccaneers and i've been trying to
convince people throughout the
off-season that round four zeke was a
good value now round one zeke yeah i get
it those days are over and if you and
you and me were running the dallas
cowboys we might very well give tony
pollard the full-time starting job over
zeke but there are things that zeke does
fantastic still namely pass protection i
mean my goodness if you saw that 49ers
game it was a third down they blitzed
two guys off the edge zeke took both of
them out i mean urban meyer say what you
want about the guy called ziko elliott
the best player he ever coached without
the ball in his hand added that he's
pretty good with the ball in his hand as
well so that's all fine and dandy but we
don't get points for pass blocking in
fantasy football and i have a feeling
that's all the cobbler is going to be
asking elliott to do in week one against
the buccaneers because we already saw
this matchup play out last year and dak
press got through the football 58 times
reminder this was dak's first game
coming off of the horrific ankle break
58 drop backs in that game ezekiel ellie
had eight pass blocking snaps that was
the second highest mark of the year just
11 carries so buccaneers defense they
have a top five defensive line in terms
of pff rankings top seven linebacker
core i think keller moore and the
cowboys recognize that this is not
really their best path to success trying
to grind zeke up the middle into that
buzz saw of a front seven that tampa bay
has so this week with zeke i would
honestly prefer josh jacobs against the
chargers in the game i think has a
better chance of shooting out miles
sanders against the lions elijah
mitchell versus the bears even clyde
edwards the lair against the cardinals
i'm starting all those guys ahead of
zeke i think we'll be back in the rb1
conversation not maybe rb1 at least
upside rb2 conversation against the
bengals next week this is not the spot
for ezekiel elliott though
couple wide receiver notes here guys and
again this is all relative so if you
have ezekiel elliott and your next
running backs michael carter or
something like that please still start
zeke i like to use matchups as a
tiebreaker if you have a guy you know
within three or four ranking spots of
each other and you're just leaning
towards a better matchup that's okay but
let's not throw out everything we know
about the guy just because of a
perceived difficult matchup but a couple
other wide receivers to talk about here
first and most namely jaylen waddle
going up against the new england
patriots so my big thing here and it's
the reason why i've been fading really
jaylen waddle throughout most of the
off-season it's just the reality that i
don't think this miami dolphins offense
led by tua tagovaila is going to be able
to be one of the most productive passing
games in the nfl because that's really
where we've been ranking these guys with
tyrique and jalen waddle both as top 24
wide receivers
that's asking a lot historically 4.3
teams per season have multiple top 24
ppr wide receivers in a single year and
just looking around the league guys not
that tua can't enable them this is not
to a slander but i look up buffalo josh
allen you know and gabriel davis and
stefan diggs the chargers justin herbert
mike williams mckinnon allen did this
last year the bengals are borough
higgins and chase broncos with russ in
town the raiders with devante and renfro
the vikings with jefferson and thielen
tampa bay the rams the cardinals i just
think there are better teams i'm gonna
put far more trust in the number two
wide receiver than the dolphins right
now so hey
waddle great player maybe he is able to
just absolutely you know figure out that
hey he is now going to be someone that's
unleashed in the new mike mcdaniel
offense i do wonder though are we really
going to see the most explosive version
of jalen waddle when he already has been
banged up with this quad injury so you
guys want to check out the chart that we
are streaming over here it's actually a
situation where i'm uh not too high on
the dolphins offense in general this
week because not only are they dealing
with you know let's patriots secondary
that no they don't have jc jackson
anymore but i think we've seen the bill
belichick impact long enough to realize
it's never going to be an easy day at
office when we're going up against this
defense so tyriko yes auto start but
jaylen waddle when we don't know what
the pecking order is going to look like
when we don't even know how healthy he
is right now i mean guys it's not a
guarantee that two is going to be airing
the ball out did you see what the 49ers
offense looked like last year with jimmy
garoppolo leading the league in yards
for attempt and it was still one of the
most run heavy slow paced offenses in
the entire league so i don't think the
volume's there for waddle and i question
because of his injury if he's gonna be
efficient enough to overcome it so this
week i prefer a monroe st brown the jlm
waddle d.k metcalf deontay johnson
gabriel davis and alan robinson so if
you have an a-rod versus waddle gabriel
davis versus waddle dilemma tonight
definitely go with them
and just a side piece of advice in
general and maybe you've heard this a
million times and you're saying i know
ian well good all right just to make
sure though you know tonight if you have
a running back that you're absolutely
making sure you know he's gonna start
make sure you have him in the rb spot
same thing with the wide receiver leave
that flex open in case disaster strikes
you need to get you know squirmy and
squirrely or whatever later in the week
trying to find eight replacements so
another wide receiver i am not liking
this week is going to be houston texans
wide receiver one brandon cooks i get it
he freaking breaks adp every single year
you know we try to fade brandon cooks he
goes to another team and what's he do he
rips off a thousand yards again and
again and again the targets are probably
going to be there but guys this is just
such a tough match up here because i
think he's gonna get that one-on-one
shadow coverage treatment from stefan
gilmore who might just be the single
best shadow cornerback in the league i
think we're gonna have a lot of people
on sunday remembering that stefan
gilmour is now on the colts and you know
over the last few years when the colts
were kind of running the more zone heavy
defense they weren't asking their
cornerbacks to travel with individual
wide receivers a lot however this year
gus bradley was on the raiders last year
utilized shadow coverage more than any
defensive coordinator in the entire
league i don't know why else they would
go out and get stefan go more if it
wasn't to feature him against the
opponent's top receiver in the texans
case it's brandon cooks and basically
nobody else so hey it's still brandon
cooks if he gets 10 targets first
anybody i think he has a decent enough
chance of putting up some okay value but
this week give me a monroe st brown
again metcalf deonte johnson gabe davis
allen robinson i do have brandon cooks
ranked outside of my top 24 receivers
and
maybe it's this damian pierce preseason
hype that's kind of causing this uh
i don't want to say new outlook on the
texans but let's just not get it twisted
the texans are still fully expected to
be one of the worst teams in football if
we look at their implied points for this
week and all applied points are is you
know every game has an over under and
every game has a spread so by kind of
taking the spread into over under we can
see how many offensive points vegas is
actually anticipating these teams to
score so seven teams this week are
implied under 20 points the bears the
falcons the jets the steelers the giants
the seahawks and the texans so it's not
the worst rule of thumb in the world
where if you have a tough you know
fantasy star sick question maybe don't
take the guy in a terrible offense and
that is exactly what the houston texans
are right now so all due respect to
davis mills but my goodness you look at
the houston texans you look at the
chicago bears i think it's impossible
for teams nfl teams to tank it's too
violent of a sport too much is going on
the field like when you're out there i
got you know instincts kick in you're
just trying to do your thing but front
offices are able to put losing teams out
there on the field i don't know how
anybody can look at the off-season
editions made in chicago and houston
over the past two all seasons and
conclude anything other than these two
teams are trying to tank
one more tough matchup i want to go over
it's amari cooper versus panthers this
is a mix of the match up and also my god
jacoby bruce is under center here i know
we spent the whole all season bashing on
you know baker mayfield and carson wentz
and some of these other guys and for
good reason if you're a browns fan
you're just disappointed by it or you
know eagles or colts fan i get it but
guys we can be objective here we can
still not be the biggest fan of baker
mayfield would admit that he's better
than career backup jacoby brissette and
that's what we're about to i think find
out in a major way on sunday so amari
cooper he's in a new offense that
offense is probably going to be the most
run heavy offense in the entire league
until deshaun watson is back under
center yeah i do think cooper is going
to be the pretty clear wide receiver one
who's to say though if he's even going
to have more targets than a david nijoku
then a kareem hunt and we're talking
again about probably fewer targets to go
around than just about any other offense
in the league right now so further
making matters tough dante jackson truly
one of the fastest players in the entire
nfl panthers number one cornerback or
number two depending on what you think
about horn but jackson was their
preferred shadow cornerback last year i
think he's gonna be tracking amari
cooper all game long did a great job in
his shadow matchups last year against
guys like brandon cooks and even stefan
diggs i believe holding them to no
touchdown so cooper i don't think he's
gonna be able to bust a big one again
against one of the fastest freaking
defensive backs in the entire league
and if you take away the big play
potential you look at the offensive
upside in cleveland it definitely isn't
what it used to be in the cowboys
reigning number lengths number one
ranked scoring offense and then finally
just the reality that cooper's also
starting to get up there in age i think
he's still only 27 right now somehow
he's been in the league forever still
but he is someone that we've seen
consistently banged up so i don't think
we're getting a good version of a
brown's offense to start and i don't
think there's gonna be much volume this
is not the situation i am looking to
target so give me devante smith hunter
renfro christian kirk elijah moore
rashad bateman i'll be taking all of
them over amari cooper in week one he's
my wide receiver 38 so just to quickly
recap everyone i am not a fan of matthew
stafford versus bills this week kirk
cousins versus the packers ezekiel
elliott versus the buccaneers jayla
model vs patriots brandon cooks vs the
colts and amari cooper versus the
panthers please don't just set them no
matter what i'm trying to not just pick
you know the wide receiver 55 of the
week and tell you guys not to sit them
it is tough to know sometimes to go
through these fades here but if you have
a close if you have a close call with
these guys i really would advise not
going to the well with them this week
all right everyone let's jump into
personalized fantasy advice presented by
state farm where the personal price plan
is all about creating a price just for
you starting off with at makamac i've
got deonte johnson i'm worried he's not
going to be productive you should be man
not only does he got to deal with you
know the mitchell trubisky experience
under center he's going to have a tough
matchup against shadobia woozier and
maybe just maybe we're not even going to
see him out there because he's dealing
with the shoulder injury right now so
with deontay johnson if you're look if
you're really in a pickle man it's going
to be a situation where look for chase
claypool look for george pickens on that
waiver wire i doubt pickens is out there
but every now and then you will see
claypool i don't think the injury is
severe enough that you need to resort to
like an isaiah mckenzie and start him
tonight but i really would try to find a
backup in some way shape or form i would
say if you have the flexbot full mike
davis the ravens probable rb1 this week
i know it sounds weird but that's a
reality it's the world we're living in
mike davis is looking at probably 15 to
20 touches this week mike davis could be
a nice last resort guy you can stick in
your starting lineup if deontay winds up
not playing
at wart damn eagle think james cook is
worth a flex spot tonight i know it's
his debut but he's quick he is quick man
no we cannot trust james cook yet though
i'm very high in him throughout the rest
of the season but right now it looks
like devin singletary is going to be the
starting running back and also zach moss
could factor in on early downs and goal
line work and now james cook probably
only gets the obvious pass down so
there's still a ceiling out there don't
cut james cook but with these rookies
sometimes we need to let that roll
develop as much as we make fun of the
you know justin jefferson like being
listed as a third team wide receiver in
the preseason he really wasn't working
as a full-time starter until week three
even as a rookie so you know justin
jefferson aj brown we've seen legit some
of the best players in the league
struggle to get on the field early it
shouldn't fault james cook for having
that same problem different position i
know but you guys get what i'm saying
from ft should i keep chase and higgins
or get rid of chase for devante adams
yeah if that's an option i think that's
fair and that's a pretty good trade
straight up so yeah i would go ahead and
do that you know chasing higgins this is
a great problem to have man because you
either have you know two top eight
receivers or you still have two top
eight receivers so i've had adam's
pretty much next to chase the entire
season i would make that deal
from at our underscore ribero who is one
sleeper you're starting this week i am
starting isaiah mckenzie in a lot of
leagues this week so he was initially on
the injury report for the buffalo bills
with that groin practice and fall all
week and didn't even have a designation
going tonight so isaiah mckenzie is good
to go and he's received starting
treatment all freaking summer long and
going through august into the preseason
as the buffalo bill is starting slot
receiver so hey a lot of times number
three receiving or an offense we're not
thrilled about it but when it's josh
allen and the most past happy team in
the nfl arguably that's what we can get
behind it so cole beasley over a hundred
targets in each of the past three
seasons that's the role isaiah mckenzie
is seemingly stepping into and with all
due respect to some of the things on the
field beasley's done over the years you
know this current edition of isaiah
mckenzie has far more juice far more yak
ability than anything beasley was able
to do at least in recent memory
from at finn's end bruce hall or damian
pierce oh my gosh this is this is a sign
of the times guys i can't believe that
we've actually reached this point but i
am going to go with damian pierce here
it just seems like michael carter is in
fact going to be the starting running
back for the jets to start the season
sometimes you know i question these
unofficial death charts that are going
out on the team i'm not sure if the head
coach is going out of his way to make
sure they're accurate or if it's just an
intern you know being told what to do
but everything we saw in the preseason 2
indicates that at least for now carter's
gonna be the first guy out there and
freeze hall still be involved but it
could be a situation where we do see
carter have the majority or even half of
the work that's a problem against a
ravens defense that i think is probably
going to completely shut down this jets
offense so damian pierce not in the best
situation either against the colts you
know we could see a situation where the
texans get behind and then unfortunately
it's rex burke head on the field instead
of damien pearce on passing downs but at
the end of the day you know which guy
has a better chance of getting 15
touches and probably both terrible
offenses i will take damian pierce
from at brock marinelli miles sanders or
tony pollard guys i really like miles
sanders this week and it's kind of funny
these uh you know quote unquote dead
zone running backs that we were fading
in season long throughout a lot of the
summer a lot of them have pretty good
matchups this week josh jacobs you know
in a potential shootout against the
chargers antonio gibson at home against
the jaguars not having to worry about
brian robinson and miles sanders against
the lions this is a fun stat i looked
this up today it's been from today 620
calendar days since miles sanders last
scored a touchdown in a professional
game come on if you're not due at that
point like what are we even doing here
talking about regression and all that
stuff so with sanders like yeah he had
the hamstring injury but once again
practicing full i don't think he's gonna
have an injury designation he said today
that he is going to play still someone
that if the eagles can get a lead
against the lions which they are favored
to do so we could look up afterwards and
see he had 20 plus touches no questions
asked so miles standards for me top 16
running back on the week and yes i would
play him over pollard
from at big body cisco start or sick
gabe davis man you got to give me the
other guys who it's between and i'll
definitely have a good answer for you
most likely start though he's my wide
receiver 22 of the week i would start
gabriel davis ahead of guys like deonte
johnson and jaylen waddle who are a
little bit banged up and also ahead of
guys like jerry judy brandon cooks who i
mentioned before darno mooney as well so
did you guys see the uh gabriel davis
peaky blinders pregame cleats i mean
what more do you need to actually see
from this guy scoring touchdowns of what
it's all about and similar to what i
just said by isaiah mckenzie like if you
can just take away everything you know
about gabriel davis and all you knew was
hey this is josh allen's number two pass
game option i think you feel pretty good
about it
from kpat who is a sleeper you're riding
with this week yeah so all right guys
isaiah mckenzie again if you need
someone to start tonight if you have you
know
just a wide receiver running back hurt
situation you're panicking isaiah
mckenzie can be the guy for you he was
going way too cheap all throughout the
off-season and we are talking about josh
allen's starting slot receiver it comes
down to literally just that we have josh
allen someone that is being picked for
mvp across the nation okay stefan diggs
i know he can do a lot maybe he will
just catch every single pass from josh
allen this year i think more guys are
going to be involved so you know isaiah
mckenzie gabriel davis dawson knox if
you have a close start sit question
don't be afraid to pick the one involved
in the better offense and this could be
tough to find many better offenses than
what buffalo is bringing to the table
this year
from at jay barajas start zeke or aj
dillon that is actually a tough one this
week oh man i know i'm fading zeke but
against aj
the more i think about it i do somewhat
lean aj dillon looking at this packers
offense
they've already called aj dylan pretty
much a starter alongside aaron jones and
in this game against the vikings yes
they do have you know zadaria smith the
neil hunter in that front seven i know
they can make some good things happen
but i wouldn't be surprised at all if we
see his packers offense embrace the run
game more and just make aaron rodgers an
overqualified uh you know basically game
manager out there so aj dillon higher
scoring upside i just think he probably
this week has a better chance to
actually be flirting with the 20
combined carries and targets meanwhile
zeke probably staying more so in pass
protection more snaps than not
from at q mcknight zeke rashad penny
as long as we get confirmation that
kenneth walker is indeed out i would be
going with rashad penny here home
against the broncos not a bad spot and
we gotta remember just how dominant
rashad penny was down the stretch of
last year so things have changed going
from russ to geno we're not getting the
same scoring upside and we also need to
consider that travis homer or dj dallas
are going to be taking away some pass
down stuff for a shot penny but let's
face it like the problem with the
seattle backfield all off season was
kenneth walker rashad penny you take
walker off the table all of a sudden
penny is much more admirable so i wish
we could uh trust anything pete carroll
had to say about the injury situation
you know when he talks about kenneth
walker being day to day i feel like that
could mean he's going to have 15 touches
on sunday or he's not going to play
until december or excuse me monday night
uh but right now
i think we're going to get the better
news on kenneth walker before monday if
you have to go into sunday and council
walker's a game time decision go with
zeke if we know for sure that kenneth
walker is out i would go with penny
from at d underscore malek goblin or a
monroe st brown answers a monroe saint
brown man definitely and with chris
goblin it does seem like he's trending
towards playing he practiced in full on
wednesday it's incredible gotta love
modern science but with the manra i just
think that his target projection needs
to be higher and unfortunately with
goblin it wouldn't make sense if they
just eased them back in or if he's just
not at his usual high level of play
right now so the buccaneers after they
signed julio jones and they gave russell
gage 30 million they don't really need
to push goblin back into the fold as
soon as possible maybe he is healthy
enough to suit up but the problem is
he's already being called a game time
decision it's going to be a sunday night
call the last thing you want is to not
play a monroe st brown get to sunday
night football and chris goblins all of
a sudden you know a late scratch start a
monroe st brown this week in leagues of
all shapes and sizes
from matt louis murphy tyler lockett or
kareem hunt in the flex i am gonna be
going with kareem hunt looking at this
browns offense i mean if you guys are
running the browns offense who would you
think you need to feed the ball to every
single play if you can nick chubb and
kareem hunt because jacoby persette is
your quarterback right now so i do think
people are maybe underrating gino smith
i think geno smith could be bad versus
horrific that's you know my big take
here i'm saying with gino uh but i'm
gonna need to see it a little bit more
before we get on with tyler lockett from
matt hey say thoughts on chris lavey
this week yeah jameis winston is one of
my favorite streaming quarterbacks
actually of this week you know going up
against atlanta yes aj tyrell is awesome
also yes aj tyrell does not travel with
individual wide receivers so i think a
lava thomas maybe even jarvis landry
they're all going to see kind of equal
portions of him so a lave kind of a thin
play you know and you're flexi someone
that could honestly be pretty boomer
bust earlier in the year but especially
in dfs i love the idea of riding with
jamison company they have honestly the
best matchup of the week in terms of
combined pressure rates falcons could
not get after anybody last year i think
james could have all day to cook himself
some crab legs in this one
from at neff martin juju or ceh have
flex this week that's a tough one man
with this chiefs offense we got the
mahomes quote calling us out you know us
fantasy football faithful saying that
he's going to have a different wide
receiver every week i do still lean
towards juju because we don't know what
this chief's backfield is going to look
like i think there's an equal chance
that clyde is the fairly featured
starter maybe not brian westbrook good
or shady good but at least the future
starter for the 2022 chiefs or we see
rojo and pacheco on early downs and
jerick mckinnon on passing downs and all
of a sudden clyde obergillar is like
stuck in the same kind of position that
antonio gibson was before the brian
robinson injury so i would go with juju
there
from matt collins 18 josh jacobs or
christian kirk into flex i think i'm
going with jacobs this week i don't hate
kirk and this could very well be flipped
you know by this time next week but with
jacobs look for trying to look for a
shootout the raiders and chargers we saw
it at the end of last season i really do
think jacobs even if we're gonna still
see some zamir white even if we're gonna
see amir abdullah on passing downs just
has an opportunity to fall into the end
zone a few times as the future back in
an offense that's gonna obviously put up
some points with derek carr and devonte
adams from matt chunky allen robinson or
brandon ayook got to go with alan
robinson tonight maybe if kittle's out
for sure we could close that gap a
little bit but to me allen robinson is a
weekly top 24 wide receiver whereas
brandon iok the talent is there to be a
top 24 wide receiver i'm not sure the
volume is going to be there we got devo
we got kittle we got trey lance making
this even a more run heavy offense it's
just a situation where i think robinson
could double the opportunities that iok
has
final question everyone really
appreciate you guys tuning in again
we'll be back here each and every week
doing this but from caleb hopkins
thoughts on starting antonio gibson this
week yes if you're not starting antonio
gibson this week i don't know when
you're going to because you know looking
at this brian robinson missing at least
four games antonio gibson now in a
position to be the featured early down
back and get a couple catches here and
there still going to see jd mckissick
but usually jd mckissick is a problem in
games where washington is going to trail
or fall behind not so much this week at
home against the jaguars gibson was
playing through a shin injury all of
last season i think we could see maybe
just a blast from the past for him get
healthy for a week show off some of that
explosiveness that made us all fall in
love with him last week antonio gibson
right there for me with josh jacobs and
miles sanders as recommended start so
that's gonna wrap up this edition of br
fantasy this has been presented by state
farm i want to thank you guys as always
for tuning in we'll be back next week
and go win this week one match up great
day to be great i'm ian hardis thanks
for tuning in until next time take care
everybody